bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france cette initiative de google peut
paraître assez surprenante alors ce que
c'est une bonne ou mauvaise idée selon
vous c'est surtout un énorme culturel
gapin c'est quelque chose qui pourrait
tout à fait apparaître comme une bonne
idée aux etats-unis en tout cas une idée
qui permet de positionner google dans un
camp politique qui lui est favorable
mais évidemment dès que ça dès que c'est
regarder d'un autre pays on a affaire à
des normes culturelles et là on met le
doigt sur l'un des plus gros culture et
le gaz qui existe entre la culture
américaine et la culture française qui
est cette notion de communauté la
communauté ça fait partie du contrat
social de base américain et c'est à
l'opposé du pacte républicain français
et on a pris notamment avec facebook
mais aujourd'hui avec google cette
vision de la société communautariste
américaine qui sait importer en france
et on a depuis déjà bien longtemps pris
un autre énorme futur al ghad qu'est la
liberté d'expression absolue façon
premier amendement qui n'existe pas en
france mais qui malgré tout a été donné
à tous les citoyens français à travers
twitter facebook et les réseaux sociaux
cette façon de signaler les commerces
tenus par des afro américains présents
tels des risques et peut-être baptisé
des violences racistes par exemple ça
paraît assez évident que dans
l'hypothèse d'une d'une émergence ou une
réémergence d'un terrorisme d'extrême
droite américains
le fait de signaler sur une carte et
commerciaux noir alors facilité les
choses
maintenant encore une fois faut faire
attention de ne pas regarder ça avec un
regard français
on a affaire une culture qui est très
différent sur ce plan-là extrêmement
différentes
et sané typiquement en rien comparable
avec le fait de mettre des étoiles
jaunes sur la population juive durant la
seconde guerre mondiale où là on
imposait aux livres de porter une étoile
jaune alors que là c'est très clairement
les noirs américains qui sont détenteurs
de commerce qui sont appelés à se
signaler en tant que tel mais c'est
aucune obligation de le faire
on l'a évoqué rapidement tout à l'heure
cette fonctionnalité c'est une manière
de surfer sur la vague anti raciste pour
google qui l'avait déjà fait pour la
communauté lgbt il y a deux ans peut-on
y voir l'indication d'un vrai engagement
politique où c'est tout simplement
commercial pour le géant d'internet les
deux cc à la fois un engagement
politique parce qu'aujourd'hui les
légats femmes
sont des acteurs politiques de premier
plan deux ont pas seulement des acteurs
économiques lors de premier plan c'est
beaucoup dire aujourd'hui apple a
dépassé en valorisation l'ensemble du
cac 40 ans on est face à des mastodontes
financiers et des trous noirs qui
absorbe tout mais on est aussi face à
une alternative aux états en matière
d'organisation de la cité est donc ce
sont des acteurs politiques de tout
premier plan
google facebook en particulier mais
aussi pourquoi pas microsoft avec les
données de santé des français pour
rebondir sur un sujet d'actualité très
français ces grosses entreprises
aujourd'hui sont des acteurs politiques
et ce sont eux qui construiront le monde
politique de demain s'il ya une notion
de vie privée qui vient aussi elle
s'appliquait pour google
est ce que cette application cette
fonctionnalité en tout cas en france
vous paraît possible non a priori en
france allait parfaitement illégal donc
on n'est pas prêt de voir arriver ça en
france on a pour l'instant juste à faire
à ce phénomène de cultural gap qui fait
que l'on jugé on regarde une culture
étrangère avec un prisme français et
comme cette culture étrangère et malgré
tout aussi dental on a beaucoup plus de
difficultés à mesurer l'étendue du
cultural gap que si on allait regarder
un pays qui est très très éloignées
notre culture ou là on aurait pour la
plupart d'entre nous la précaution de 2
prenant en compte cet immense distance
culturelle
là ce sont les états unis on est abreuvé
de culture américaine depuis maintenant
des décennies des décennies et on a
tendance à penser que c'est une culture
qui est très proche
or sur ces deux sujets qui sont
totalement fondamentaux à la fois pour
les états unis mais aussi très
concrètement aujourd'hui pour la france
ces deux cultures qui sont extrêmement
différentes
et comme il y en a une ça ne vous aura
pas échappé qui est bien plus puissante
que l'autre elle est en train de
s'imposer
on voit ça à travers une multitude
d'événements qui vont des états unis à
la france en l'espace de quelques jours
quelques heures parfois quelques mois et
qui se traduisent dans les cultures
français c'est qu'ils donnent autre
chose
on a eu typiquement le mythe ou qui est
devenu balances ton port est quelque
chose de différent c'est pas le mythe ou
c'est une adaptation française du mythe
ou un contexte culturel français on a eu
blacklight batteur ce qui est devenu
tout ce qui tourne autour d' adama
traoré en france là aussi c'est une
transposition est une adaptation locale
mais ça n'est pas vraiment
comparable à la réalité de la population
noire aux etats unis c'est pas le même
passé c'est pas les mêmes revendications
c'est pas la même histoire et dans ce
grand jeu de mondialisation de la
société que je clairement joué par les
gars femmes
et bien c'est ces transformations à
coups de boutoir de la société française
à travers les réseaux sociaux sont
parfois extrêmement rude celui là celui
des communautés va être extrêmement rude
pour la société française
merci beaucoup fabrice epelboin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes enseignant à sciences po et
spécialiste des réseaux sociaux